today's met office report looks at last
year's weather but more crucially its
impact
2021 was another year in a pattern of
warming
that's changing things we take for
granted
spring is getting hotter and wetter
and the seasons are shifting now the
warmer weather has really sped up fruit
ripening in and and nuts for me now what
that means is it sounds well what's the
problem with that but actually that
happening earlier can have a really
disastrous effect for wildlife because
they may not have the food source
available later in autumn when they need
it so there's real jeopardy for some
species here yeah there's real jeopardy
or not we're in massive species decline
already
[Applause]
what's interesting about looking at last
year's weather is in some respects how
unremarkable it actually was in 2021
there were no extreme record highs but
why that is interesting is that if you
take that 12 months and look at it in a
broader context even without a record
high it was still one of the hottest
years on
record look at this at how much warmer
2021 was than the average hottest day of
the year just a few decades ago
and remember today's report doesn't look
at this year 2022 that has already
changed the game entirely with the uk
average temperature exceeding 30 degrees
celsius for the first time ever
as climates change extremes become more
frequent last year saw storm irwin
batter parts of the uk with high winds
and snow eight months later just last
week it was that blistering heat
our natural world can adapt to gradual
change but shocks like extreme weather
in addition to our warming climate could
push some species too far to a point
beyond which they cannot recover
cattlemen over totsi sky news